Michael Shermer is the author of many
books the founding publisher of skeptic
magazine and is very skeptical of
everything I'm saying right now you you
are a professional skeptic yeah is it
worried well given that I published a
magazine called skeptic I guess that's
technically true yeah and you run
skeptic calm so you've got the we've got
a book called skeptic right here yeah
you're a skeptical dude yeah I am NOT by
nature necessarily I I would like to
believe lots of things I'd like to
believe that the stock market is not
cater cratering this week you know I'd
like to believe that you know aliens are
out there and visiting this you know
there's a lot of things if there was an
afterlife you know I'd like to live for
centuries to see how all this turns out
you know but the fact that I'd like it
to be true does it make it true so I
have to kind of override my own
subjective biases and preferences in
favor of the facts which is sometimes
hard to face yeah so I started the show
by talking about reason and using logic
and science to get a sense of morality
which you've written a lot about but
before we get into that I want to talk a
little bit about your history and your
sort of evolution to getting to where
you are so you weren't
oh you didn't grow up religious right
but you but you became religious for a
small period of time around high school
or late high school can you tell me yeah
when I was a evangelical born-again
Christian in high school in college for
my four years undergraduate and in the
start of graduate so about seven years
total my parents weren't religious but
they weren't anti religious you know
back then the whole atheism thing was
not a thing it was just something most
people didn't talk about but the
born-again movement was kind of picking
up in the 70s and my friends were into
it in high school so you know it's that
that so after parental influence then
there's peer group influence and that's
was my case my friends were doing it
yeah I remember my friend Frank was
really religious and when I became
became a born-again it happened at a
Presbyterian Church because this other
friend of mine went there and when I
came back to school on Monday told Frank
I did it you know I went to the
Presbyterian Church he goes no no that's
the wrong one which one did he weigh
Jehovah Witness right yeah so I'm like
wrong one
oh okay so that was my first inkling
that okay there's these little factions
and tribes even within the within the
Christian Christianity movement right
anyway but I took it fairly seriously
and I went to Bible classes and then I
went to Pepperdine which is a Church of
Christ school very conservative Jerry
but President Ford came to speak and you
know it was a it was in a bubble that
where everybody believed and you know
when you're in the bubble
psychologically it makes sense it's
logically coherent it's internally
consistent and everything falls into
place and it's not really until you're
out of the bubble and you encounter
other worldviews that you think huh you
know maybe maybe mine's not so solid as
I thought and that was how I kind of
chipped away at it later right so what
kind of stuff were you questioning
before you got into the bubble that led
you to jumping in and becoming
born-again and actually before you
before I let you answer that when you're
born again I always think of born again
as someone that's left the religion and
come back and that's why they're born
again oh no that's born again just means
you're born physically and then you're
born again when you accept Jesus as your
Savior right it's sort of a new you
start life anew
and you get eternal life because you've
accepted Jesus so that's what they mean
by born again yeah and and evangelical
they mean you were supposed to
evangelize so this is why evangelicals
are always talking to people about Jesus
where they will hold up the placards at
sporting events John 3:16 for God so
loved the world he gave His only
begotten Son for you and they they wear
the black face and football with the
three John 3:16 Yeah right and they
thank God after they win yes so the idea
is that you you wear it on your sleeve
you you know you're the the shining
beacon on the hill you do not hide your
faith underneath a bushel basket you
tell people about it and in a way you
kind of have a moral obligation to do so
because if you know that this is the way
the truth and the light and you get
eternal you know eternity for this
person's soul you really have to tell
them about it they're missing out so
it's not like the old school like maybe
George HW Bush's myth you know he was a
Methodist and they're pretty quiet about
it you know
you believe what you believe I believe
what I believe and we just don't talk
about it evangelicals and I like that
they're more like a charge W Bush you
know you tell people Jesus was my
favorite philosopher and I'm a
born-again and you witness to people
yeah literally going door to door and I
did that obnoxiously so so you did all
that and then you're in the bubble and
then what caused the chipping away that
led you to sitting well I went to
graduate school at Cal State Fullerton
which is a secular school so and it's
not again it wasn't that atheism was a
big thing it was just that no one was
religious or if they were they were
quiet about it
and so I began taking classes in you
know social psychology anthropology and
I can see the you know psychological
basis of belief and where you happen to
been born determines what you believe
and particularly in anthropology you
study all these indigenous peoples who
never even heard of Jesus Christ let
alone Christianity or anything like that
you know and it's like well why why
would they be condemned they don't even
know about it right you know so ah well
they you know God has a special place
for them a little weigh station or
something you know what about the Jews I
mean they you know they believe pretty
much everything I believe but except
Jesus well if God has a special
placement okay well you know how did how
does this all work you know yeah and
then also the problem of evil I I never
thought that they predict that Chris
theologians provided a cogent answer to
that why bad things happen to good
people yeah and I don't mean like
homicide you know okay so we have a
human nature we're sinful so people do
bad things that's the quick answer to
that
why childhood leukemia you know why
tsunamis that wipe out entire villages
of you know in tiny children that you
know why should why do they have to
suffer sure and and beyond the because
God works in mysterious ways and he has
a plan for everybody which was never
satisfying to me you know that pretty
much did it in and then finally well I
wrote about this you know my girlfriend
at the time was in a car accident and
broke her back and and I was pretty much
on the way out at that point but I
remember it being at the emergency room
thinking this poor woman I mean she is
the sweetest lady and why would this
happen to her this is not right you know
so I sort of made one last-ditch effort
and prayed you know and it's not that
this was the big test
and if it fails and I won't believe it's
just like you know what of course she's
still paralyzed today you know it's like
okay you know I just don't think there's
anybody up there pulling the strings
yeah so why do you think so many people
are just afraid to say I don't know
because that seems to me to be the real
question and the real basis is sort of
everything that you do you're not
proclaiming to know any sort of wisdom
that I don't know right I mean we know
different things but you're not
proclaiming to have the answers and
people are so afraid of that question
what do you what do you think that's
about well I think cognitively we know
now that once you comprehend an idea a
concept anything the brain automatically
just believes it to be true just accepts
it as part of the factual world that is
and then being skeptical of it or saying
I don't know I'm not sure or I
challenges is an extra cognitive load
you can do it lets people do so think of
the difference between type 1 and type 2
thinking type 1 cognition is rapid
intuitive instinctive emotional type 2
thinking is deliberate slow methodical
rational and and most of our thought
processes that we initiate are type 1 we
just kinda have a feeling about things
with gut instinct go about the world and
type 2 requires okay wait let me stop
and think about maybe I shouldn't make
that investment maybe I better not marry
this person maybe I shouldn't buy that
company whatever it is that requires
additional step so it's an extra
cognitive load it's uncomfortable it
takes time and anyway and that's true
with with religious beliefs I think you
know it just feels like you know the
earth is the center of everything we're
we're the center of creation God's here
for me it just you know everything that
happens happens for a reason it just
kind of feels right so it's really just
I mean it's just as simple as comfort
really is what you're saying it's just
like there's some stuff out there that I
don't understand and I better just pick
this belief because then I don't have to
spend that much mental energy on right
it's almost like you know the
creationist arguments or arguments of
people about you know who built the
pyramids or whatever it's just well God
did it or the aliens did it
and then and then for me to deconstruct
the whole thing like in a debate or on a
TV show you know I have to go through
well how do you know what happen right
you've got 15 minutes to explain natural
selection or you know whatever it's just
easier to go God did it man right so is
some of that also the way our technology
works now with Twitter of 140 characters
and behind of 6 seconds and all these
things those are what you just described
those are type 1 thinking right because
it's just quick easy stuff and this I
guess is type 2 where we're actually
going in and out of an idea but in a way
it would be really hard for type 2 to
ever win the great debate you don't have
time it does win but it takes time and
it's delivered and it takes effort it's
uncomfortable you know Sam Harris's
doctoral thesis was based on this idea
of scanning brains why they read what
people read statements that are
obviously true obviously false or you
can't tell you just don't know and he
showed that that the brain activity is
very rapid and simple and easy and
positively reinforced with dopamine for
questions that were obviously true or
false the ones were that you had to
deliberate on and so on were the areas
of the brain that lit up were not not
only did it happen slower but they were
associated with things like bad smell
and disgust and negative emotions so
really you know an idea that stinks or
an idea that's but in other words being
skeptical saying I now comprehend this
and I doubt it right it's a little bit
like my line is cognitively a heavier
load because you have to know what the
truth is and then take another step and
okay now I'm going to manipulate the
truth in this particular way and I have
to remember both of those and then maybe
you tell it to a third person now you
got it three different stories you got
so that load gets heavier and it's
harder and it's it's just easier you
know to go the simple route yeah did you
happen to see Sam's blog post around
Christmastime about lighting lighting a
fire oh yes it was a really interesting
piece because a lot of what we're
talking but it's not just couched in
religion I think that's what his point
was that he said he was saying that
we're all comforted by a nice fire
prevent fire but then he goes into the
carcinogens and the toxins and all this
horrible
and I read it that day and then I did
light a fire that I think I read it on
Christmas Eve and I lit a fire and I
think it Illustrated his point perfectly
like we have this idea we really like
the fire right it's a really nice
comforting thing and then we can
cognitively know that it's doing a lot
of damage to us so not all crazy beliefs
and crazy actions are sort of based in
religion that's right I mean it goes
across the spectrum again it aliens are
like deities for atheists as I call them
you know it's it weird even if you don't
believe in God but there's somebody out
there who who's looking out for us who
knows we're here
loves us may be looking out for us
morally something like that that's kind
of how aliens are described in a way it
is like somebody cares about me it's
like the fire it makes you feel good
yeah the afterlife is like that as well
you know we're all set scores are
settled you know we're you get to have
the perfect body in your 29 years old
right and you know and so on and and and
all justice is served and that just
feels good I mean that's the way the
world should be and you can just look
around and go well it isn't so you know
it's so funny what people take comfort
in because just this past weekend I was
watching The History Channel but you
know they've gone from what once was
history now they do a lot of God stuff
right so I think it was God versus the
devil was the name of the show or God
God verse Satan or one of these things
and there was so much horrible imagery
you know you mean burning people and
endless war and Armageddon and all this
stuff and I kept thinking the entire
time this is incredible to me I mean
this is what people are taking comfort
in yes but it was pretty horrible stuff
so that right there shows a cognitive
diskin well so part of that is that
we're also moralizing animals moralizing
primates we care deeply about justice
and right and wrong so it's not just we
want a good life an easy life a life
with you know plenty of food and water
and you know milk and honey and you know
that it's not just that we want to we
want to cause we can be behind that we
feel is a good cause and all causes have
to have an anti cause you know well
who's preventing us from achieving this
utopians it's those guys those bad guys
over there you know and they're
preventing us from having eternal bliss
forever how bad are they they are really
bad right and what does that mean we can
do to them whatever we want because
they're so bad and that's what leads to
genocide and wars and conflicts even
homicides you know 90% of homicides are
moralistic in nature the guy deserved to
die why well he scratched my car he
insulted me or he stole my girlfriend or
you know whatever they're always these
these kind of moralistic reasons so
there was an interesting commentary on
this recently about the interest in
Trump and other strong leaders and then
reflecting back on the interest of in
Mussolini and Hitler back in the 30s and
George Orwell writing about this saying
I really get this you can see the
passion and the people it's not just
that Hitler or Mussolini said I will
give you economic prosperity and jobs
and in three square meals a day it's
that we are gonna change the world we
are gonna make Germany great again or
really great again and so it's about
easy answers then right again going to
your type-1 thinking and these guys like
Trump that just black and white that's
very simple yeah simple stuff so how do
we and and this is I guess really what
you've done you know sort of more than
Hillis how do we wrestle that
conversation back and get it to a place
where people are willing to extrapolate
ideas and and open them up and you can
get in there and really figure out
what's going on hard to do how do we do
it well you do what we're doing now but
most people don't sit down like this you
know you go to a bar or whatever and
it's it's much more black and white
right in part I think the diffusion of
culture through the internet and all the
radio stations and television stations
helps you know despite this a History
Channel too with the ancient aliens and
stuff you know it's like they're all
formally all Hitler all the time now
it's all conspiracy then it's all
Bigfoot than it's all aliens right right
yes I know but at least there's and I
love that stuff but we're gonna talk a
little bit about it I love that stuff
but I know that you know they're just
playing with your mind like right good
to remember television is a series of
commercials with blank spots in between
they have to be filled with something
interesting to keep you from the clicker
right clicker culture so well and then
literacy rates you know but the more the
more literate people are the more they
read the more options they have so it's
true Twitter 140 characters but you can
betta link to an article that maybe is
3,000 words and then maybe from there
you go to the 10,000 word analysis from
there you go to the book and so anyway
as a book author I like to think maybe
I'm delusional here that people still
like to read long books
I hope yeah and and move from the
Twitter to you know to Facebook listen I
I hope so too that's why I'm doing this
that's exactly why I'm doing this